[Music]
Darkness imprisoning me all that I
see it's the celebration of a birth
that's why you don't like it it's true
you probably don't like Christianity or
God or the moral order because you are
persisting in something that we all know
including you is obviously wrong it's
terrible to kill a baby it's time to
stop but probably the reason that this
fanatical Pro abortion person really
hates Christmas is is that it's the
Feast of the Nativity it's about the
birth of our Lord probably she would do
a little bit better with really any
other Christian Feast Michael miss or
you know Easter or something but Feast
of the Nativity is much harder